oh no no i justed the camera for you
raid that [ __ ] hello I'm Greg and I'm
Kyle Kyle I Lerman the kaibaman on
Twitter and Instagram he's working on
YouTube shower now called fan theory you
can catch him with his episodes on
periscope wine and wild right that's
correct
I was on an episode recently he was I
was considered the best episode he's
ever done actually yeah we're both my
Marvel shirts but there's a video here
called what if Superman got sick by
cartoon hooligan oh it sounds great I
love cartoon hooligans
this is requested by Lovisa najuk oh
that's a great name I think that's what
you seek Superman BB never felt like
this before
Wow go good what you will be back at the
end of the situation that's fine I just
use the bank decides oh you know I'll do
that come on let's go take this
dude you're Sofie fly dream able to grow
are you sure about this I'm Superman
I get beauty what even if I am let me do
my date ruh-roh seeker Eddie everyone
knows your name is Bruce and your
father's business partner okay big guy
let's get this over it's not the first
time you tried to Stuart ears and every
single time you get your free stuff I'll
give you that
look at this wow that really hurts dude
you got the wrong car diplom there she's
gonna check it out look what you did to
my head never happened before
Superman sickness thinks of weakness
power somehow next flu virus must be
suppressing some wrench Kryptonian genes
and affecting its brain resulting and
losing Emma this tower stood rarely
graduation and also cost many have
unexpected words we can solve the
behavior
[Music]
Oh believe it this condition is being a
worse than I imagined
the virus is not just caused in Toulouse
a spider's magnetic iron is also
exponentially increase the hormonal
level into the men's body that's
something for a teenager with raging
hormones right now Batman Superman is
gone again where's the other side you're
not welcome here you're back to your own
universe
you can't Oh book there must be a
mistake
we've known each other for years I'm
John no Hulk how could he do that I told
you a friend I miss home Batman I want
to go back
well John Oh could you have grown into
laughing hey guys guys good Tommy please
what'd I do wrong oh yeah Oh Eddie was
there oh oh man it's not in real life
forces me out but it's on other people
oh really yeah just like a giant green
snotty and all think and if everything
is yummy sounds like the one day little
bad though I don't like that can I just
point out that I love that ever since
the dark night especially Batman it's
always a really yeah it was great about
that animation is it looks like it could
be a legit animation okay so it looks
more than just a spook parody what it's
like anime ish well yeah got like a me
style to it yeah it could be like one of
their plenty of just this week another
way oh yeah there's like a Teen Titans
show that just kind of like them move
dial yeah it actually made it a lot
easier to to grasp what was going on in
it because at times actually is like and
the first half I was getting a little
concerned for Superman I was like what's
going on with him know what's happening
in this part of the comic story laughs
what's going on is Superman getting sick
I can see that I especially love the the
levitate III seat from there everybody
yeah they're all running the same unit
immature yeah what they could have done
is done to the Sun you know because then
the sooner I get out of the Sun getting
it healed from the Sun yeah it makes
perfect sense that makes perfect sense
I don't know why they just couldn't do
that whenever I get sick in the first
place
probably at PD those are the symptoms of
an STD if I'm not mistaken you think
Louis yeah Louis was sleeping around
with Jimmy as a daily planner yeah I
love the exposition when when back in
back
and then it's two then it's happened
this way and this way and I just love
when that happens especially when it's
like super perfect I go to super on
purpose and him looking in the locker
room that is something I thought
Superman I always were wondering why
didn't that happen sooner that she seems
like there was no one done that yet in
the comics you know I guess you / boy
would have done that at least I mean
maybe it's because his personality is
kind of like Captain America is in the
sense that he's very noble interests
yeah I think so that's probably why but
still I mean he would do he would he
would use it at least one have you ever
looked in a locker room or known anyone
who's done that I've never done that
well not with x-ray vision you know in a
night movie there was alike they had the
hole carved into the locker room how
he's actually seeing our keys yeah yeah
that I've never done that I've never
done that never done that I've always
thought even when I was young I would I
did one where I didn't want to do when I
was in in middle school it was by
accident was trying to get my key for my
locker during gym class and I went in on
all the girls because the teacher was a
woman for the gym class ah she wouldn't
she had to get I to get me pee from her
and so she like just come on in
she thought was a girl oh and then all
the girls thought I was a [ __ ]
pervert pervert did you uh did did you
like it when you're in middle school was
really awesome and then of course all
the guys come up to you give you a pound
of back yeah that's just exciting when
you're young if you see like Naik's now
it's like I was like a some random boat
trip and they were like across the water
like a bunch of like Nate topless girls
it wasn't like super ecstatic to me and
now that I'm in my 20s and like cher is
cool that they're naked but see naked
girls before you know but I know when
you're young and let's be awesome so if
you had an x-ray vision you would
absolutely use it to I don't know if I
would absolutely use it would you say
you at least want to like leave
yeah this is supposed to be the whisper
but I just sucked in regulars oh sorry
my mouth yeah but Supergirl in the
locker room uh so that's really sick
well that's the thing about Superman and
Supergirl growing up I didn't realize
there were cousins I mean one just Oh
like I was close to being a teen I'm
like oh [ __ ] they're cousin so yeah they
didn't have any interest in finding out
anything about Supergirl so I always
thought super general Superman would
have been a great couple you know so
what if their cousins from a different
planet doesn't mean something
genetically Robin's when they go on what
if their genes work a little different
the thing I will say is I have proof
that sometimes cousins find each other
attractive yeah my brother he looked at
a cell phone message you got from one of
his buddies who was dating my cousin at
the time Wow and it was your tip and he
goes nice to which he he he shows the
rest of the image and it's purchased
with my cut well man I've met people who
yeah like at one time I met a girl
Leonard of being my cousin and I thought
she was like beautiful and then it
happens you know you have to like rewire
your brain instantaneously and go you
know don't sleep anything like that
about you at all you know yeah I got a
good-looking cousin but I try to tell
myself they're not so yeah yeah that's a
smart smart thing to do but I feel like
Superman Supergirl would totally be off
I think there's there must be some type
of like comic book spin-off where they
get together
I'm sure or like a great thing for the
DCE you to do or I mean cuz DC does use
kind of alternate dimensions and
universes a lot so it could just be like
they're not genetically related true and
then it wouldn't be as weird they might
just be cousins because they're from
Krypton because anyone who comes from
Krypton would have the Superman powers
yeah it's like hey cuz yeah exactly
alright well you can subscribe to the
real reject subscribe to cartoon
hooligan kyle is the Kyler man on
Twitter and Instagram wine and wild
episodes from Paris coffee and he's also
starting up a channel called span theory
yep not film Theory fan Theory all one
word all one word and it'll be more
prevalent when
it really blows up I hope it was a mmm
I'll be there I'll be there blow up
another loop over there blow up never
blow you go you upside okay I'm never
blaring OVA yeah